サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナササナン
ではよろしくお願いします
えっとまあ 今日はこのダンマパダのいくつかの教訓になりました
まあこの かなり何回も何回もね
この芸の解説をしたと思いますが
今日はテシロさんがね
大震災の三年目 四年目ということでね
それにふさわしい何か説法にした方がいいっていうことになりましたので
うーん そういうことで生きるっていうことはどういうことかっていうことはまあ考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
で 私たちはね ずいぶん調子に乗ってね
生きてますけどね 人間生きてる時はよくある一つ
誰にでもある考えってね
明日がありますというね
みんな明日を目指して生きているんです
明日あるさという感じでね
だから家を作る時でも
この明日があるから家を作るんですね
仕事をする時でも 畑 田んぼを耕す時
耕す時でも 明日があるということでね
で 生きているんです だから
この明日があるんだという気持ちがずっと心の中に入ってしまっちゃって
もう気づかないんですね
で 自分が明日のために生きているんだということに気づかないんですね
この明日という言葉はね
ちょっと象徴的な言葉で
今ではない先というね
だから今の人生っていうのには大したことがなくて
しっかり生きるの明日なんです
で これがこの こういう言葉でちょっとかっこいい言葉を今考えてるんだけどね
思い出せるかどうかわかりませんだけどね
時間という概念にね 閉じ込められているんですね Trapped
in the time これ英語で思い出しちゃってね
意味がないんだからね
日本語にならないんですね
時間にはめられている
この時間とは頭の観念なんですね
いわゆる妄想の一つなんです
それにはまっていてなかなか抜けられない
からの夢にはまった 例えば
これはありえない話かもしれませんだけど
人がずっと寝ていて この人には何かちょっと脳に異常が何かありまして
目覚めません ずっと寝ている
それで何か一つの夢を見ると
その夢が終わったら ずっと寝ているんだけど
またループループで同じ夢を繰り返しちゃうと
これとっても大変 もうおっかな状態なんですね
夢だから何か何を妄想したってもいいんだけどね
例えば森の中を歩いていて
まあそこでもう獣が追っかけてきて
もう殺され必死で走っちゃって
ここでまたドカンと何かでストップしちゃって
また猛獣が追っかけてきて
また同じことを繰り返しちゃうと
こっからでしょう 逆なことでもね
まあお腹が空いて みんなものすごいごちそう用意して
まあじゃあこれから人だけ食べようとしたら
もう全部食べ物はなくなりましたと
それで夢ワンサイクルが終わっちゃって
また夢の中でお腹が空いちゃって
それでちょっと周り見たらみんなかなりごちそう用意していて
それでみんなご挨拶全部終わっちゃって
では食べようとか またそれ消えちゃうとかね
そういう風にこの夢の中に取って
何でしたっけ 夢って罠にはめられちゃうとかなり大変なんですね
時々私たちは目覚めるんだからね
もう本当に助かりますけど
時々一般の方々もかなりこの夢にはめられてしまって
このトラップティンで罠にかけられてね
いる状態 それは結構精神的にダメージを受けるんですね
このトラップはね この罠はね
あの時間は我々の頭が作った一つの妄想で
で 妄想だからケロッと笑って捨てちゃえばいいでしょうね
時々我々いろんなくだらんことを妄想するでしょう
結構楽しいんですね 妄想やと言って
それからまあまあ捨てちゃう
あまり真剣に乗りません
だったら別にどうってことはないんです
でも時間はそうじゃないんですね
時間という罠にはめられちゃって抜けられない
これなぜ抜けられないかと
自分の妄想だから いろんな精神的な病気の方々いるでしょ
精神病っていうのはもうもう肉体の病気の数より精神の病気の数が多いんですね
あれ何だか分からないんですね
肉体の病気では高血圧やらあれやこれやとかね
糖尿病とかね すごいシンプルなんですね
目の病気 耳の病気 それはまあ目が病気にならなければこんな程度っていうことはまあ大体は知ってますしね
耳の病気だったら まあ耳は 3つありますから
どちらでしょうか どんな炎症でしょうかっていうことでね
治療できるかできないか関係なく
大体わかるんですね 時々珍しい病気にかかっても
医者が堂々と言うでしょ
これはもう 20万人に 100
万人に 300万人に一人にしかかからない病気だとかね
すぐ見つかっちゃいますね
治療はないんだけど 見つかるんですね
それより数が 多いんですよ
精神病名は 気持ち悪いんだから私はもう調べないんだけど
なんか精神病ってどれぐらい全部あるのかと
もう調べたいっていう気持ちもないわけでもないんだけど
ああいう文章を読んだりするっていうのはすっごい気持ち悪いんだから読まない
調べようとはしないんです
で またまあややこしい病名
すごい難しいんですね
英語にしてももう骨が折れるんで
あんな単語を覚えるためには
それで偉そうにあなたはこの子の精神病
あなたはこの子の精神病とはもう名前をつけるんですね
これでこの病人の人々も面白いんですね
先生があなたは分列病ですと言ってきたら
すっごくこれで誇りに思っちゃうんですね
実はお坊さん 私はこういう診断を受けているものですけど
帰れと言いたくなるんですね
こちら来て欲しくないんですね
自分で何かなりますかと
自分の病気が誇りに思ってるね
人が治らないでしょう
これであの精神病っていうのは
この心理学の勉強している人々は
これを商売であらゆる現象にラベル貼るだけで
あのどんな風な現象でしょうか
それに何かラベル貼る
現象と言えばキリがないでしょうね
例えば恐怖感であっても
恐怖感によっていろいろ犬は怖いとかね
女性は異性は怖いとかね
いろんな怖さが出てきますよ
だから異性は異性は怖いという精神病には一つの名前で
それは足らないと言って
まあ男は男性女性嫌いと思ったらこの名前で
女性は男性のこと見ただけで嫌いって言った時
こういう名前で名前増やしちゃうんですね
じゃあ一般的な人間が怖い
細菌が怖いとかね あれもそれにも人間が怖いっていうの
また別な病名があります
ただ 細菌は怖いと言って暴れちゃうとは別な病名がありましてね
もう切りがなくあります
その理由は治療できません
西洋とか現代心理学ではね
精神病気には何一つも治療できません
直したことは一度もないんです
まあ軽い場合はね このカウンセラーと話し合ってね
まあいわゆる喋ってみてね
いろいろ まあその場合はいくらか
まあなんとか緩和する場合はありますね
また発病するということは
なかなかそれは切らないんですね
そこで何で精神病を例にしたかというと
あれも自分が作った妄想にのループに閉じ込められているんですね
逃げられない 同じことをぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる妄想する
例えば細菌はありますよ
あ 細菌怖いと思ったら
これ妄想でしょうに 自分の体が今とっくに細菌だらけだから
何考えてるんですかね
何かお腹の中の細菌も何か 1kgぐらいあるみたいですね
もう種類もすっごいたくさん種類がありまして
現代知ってるものも全く知らない細菌もありましてね
誰も持ってますよ もしそれがなくちゃったら
なくなったら直ちに人が死んじゃいます
だからみんなに人気あって
覚え 思い 覚えられる 覚えたいとかね
あれだって 例えばこのいくら食べても太らない
スマートでいられる人も
ちょっと食べたらガクッと膨らませちゃう
あれも腸の細菌だそうです
だからマウスのね したらこの細菌入れ替えたりしちゃうと
この痩せてくれる細菌入れちゃうと食べさせても痩せたまんまで太る
これ取り上げちゃうとマウスは太ってしまうとね
だから細菌がいいとも悪いともなく共存していることで
これは結婚していることと同じ
結婚相手が敵か味方かさっぱりわからないでしょ
まあとにかく まあ一応死ぬまで一緒にいるんで共存しているんですね
だから敵でも味方でもなくて
共存しているだけの話なんです
だから細菌の場合も結婚した相手と同じだと思っちゃえばいいんです
別に 最高に幸福幸せってわけでもないし
極端に悪人を似てるわけでもなくて
もう死ぬめんどくさい
じゃあ亡くなって 亡くなっても困りますと
言ったら困りますよと
どっちかと まあそんなもんですね
結婚生活っていうのは
いることも嫌ですね いなくなって
それも嫌なんです だからその場合はこの共存という言葉で理解しなくちゃいけないんです
だから共存というのは
あの この 何と言いますか
すごい純粋に幸せでも純粋不幸でもないんですね
ごちゃごちゃなんです
だからそれ理解できればありがたいんだけど
この細菌に対しても同じことで
しかし妄想しちゃう 細菌怖い
不潔 汚いやと 細菌いないところはいない
ないでしょうに よく見ると
この他のでっかい巨体持ってる生命たちがもう勝手に威張ってるだけで
全て支配管理しているのはあの小さな細菌たちなんですね
細胞一個見ても中入り込んでるんですね
でなくて細胞生きていられないんです
だから細菌ないところは何もない
でもいるんですね そういう精神的な病気にかかる人っていうのは
細菌は怖い だから服洗うは体洗うは
もう部屋の中をずっと掃除するわ
外へ出られなくなっちゃうわ
で どういうことですかね
ちょっとした妄想を作っちゃって
そのトラップに閉じ込められたんですね
だから同じことを繰り返し
繰り返し繰り返しやって
ひどい目に遭います そこで脱線はそのところにして話に戻りますけど
時間ということも同じ
我々がはめられている罠なんです
逃げられないんですね
それで精神的な病気の人が苦しんでいるように
同じく我々もものすごく苦しんでいるんです
ものすごく苦しんでいるんです
[終始背景音楽]過去のことを思い出しては苦しむ
あれは失敗しました ああではなかった
あれやらなかった方がよかった
あれこれとかね 今更何をと
で 将来のことで あらゆることで苦しむ
子供は無事成長するのか
卒業できるのか いい仕事を見つかるのか
いい結婚相手見つかる
何でも自分が病気にかかったらどうしようかと
お金がなくなったらどうしよう
全て妄想で幻覚であって悩みじゃないんです
本当は苦しみでも何でもないんです
ただ 自分がこの時間という罠にはめたら
そこにあるのは苦しみなんです
時間という妄想概念を捨ててしまうと
今の瞬間 ただ単にいるだけなんですね
それは流れるということもわかってくる
今の瞬間終わったら今の瞬間
次の瞬間ではないんです
今 今 今の瞬間の流れなんですね
これ終わったら次と思ったら
時間の問題に入ります
病気になります 今の瞬間終わったら今の瞬間なんです
だから生きるのは今の瞬間で
今の瞬間では何の問題もないんです
たとえ足が痛くても 全くへっちゃらで何のこともないんです
悩み苦しみの原因にならない
これで悩むのかいと 今お腹が空いたという感じがあったって
別になんのこともないんです
それに時間入れてください
あ 昼ご飯食べ忘れちゃったとか
あ 栄養足りなくない？どうしようかとかね
で これもう話にこのお坊さんなかなか終わらないブレーキがないんだから
晩ご飯もこれにこれでも悩みますよ
だから苦しみたければ
悩みたければ 極端の苦しみの中で生きたければ
過去か将来に行ってみてください
いくらでもいけます ただ
だって現実じゃない 妄想だから
夢だから これこの癖がものすごい強烈に入ってるんですね
何考えたっても時間に汚染されている
例えばこの本も あ ちょっと古くなっている
思った途端 時間にはめられているんです
でなくちゃ この本そのまま見てほって
何の価値もなく いいも悪いもなく
そういうことかっていうことで観察することはできるんです
時間入れた途端 全て終わり
そこで皆様も自分の思考の中でこのドリームと何考えても時間に行っちゃう
まあ料理作ろうかなとかね
まあ私は料理できんだからね
まあ卵焼き程度ですけど
じゃあ卵焼きにします
もう卵焼き 出来が悪いと悩んでるでしょ
なんで？時間 出来が悪いと言えますかね
過去何かのサンプルがなければ
妄想の中で 頭の中で 過去で誰かがあれば店で作った
何ですか 卵焼きとかね
そういう過去のイメージがあったら
ああ これは出来が悪い
やっぱり私って下手ですねとかね
いくらでも悩みます なんでそれが出来だと思わないんですかね
それで私はこの油使いませんだから卵焼きは作ります
空のフライパンで これ相当の腕が必要なんです
で それからこの 火の扱いはね
もうかなり精密にやらなくちゃあかんです
教えてあげますけど あの
ちょっと火をつけて あの強くではなくてね
中ぐらいにして あのパンもね
まあ壊れますから ちょっと温める状態にして
それから極細くするんです
火を それで卵入れちゃうんです
入れて秒 秒ぐらい  で もう蓋しなくちゃあかんですね
で 二 三十秒ぐらい寄ったら火を消しちゃうんです
消えてそのまま置いとくんです
それでまあ出来上がり
ちゃんと外せます 何のことなく
でもこの秒は数えてないんだから
全部この勘でやってますから
まあ成功する時もあるし
失敗する時もありますけど
ではこの成功失敗ってどんな言葉
成功したら気分がいいでしょ
失敗したら気分が悪い
あれ過去なんです それで悩みが生まれたんです
もしベッタシつけちゃってね
卵がね もうもうもう消すって皿に入れなくちゃいけない
この卵焼きではなくて
なんか卵焼き粉っていう感じになったとしたら
でも食べられるでしょうに
だからその瞬間喜べば何の問題もないんです
だから人間の不幸はそうやってこの時間のトラップ
トラップって時間の罠にはめられてるんだから
これも幻覚の罠なんです
んで 喜んで はい 次 誰でもそうやって明日のために生きてるんだから
誰も生きてないんです
人間は 明るくて 元気で
力いっぱい活発で 溢れる幸福感で楽しみがあって
穏やかで 安穏で はい 今楽しく生きてる
今生きてる それは経験したことがないんです
この究極の安穏は経験したことがないんです
みんな生きたことがないんです
みんな準備しているだけ
支度中 それで死んでしまっちゃいます
なんで家がな されたら悲しいんですかね
なんで津波で親戚やら親しい人々が亡くなった悲しいかというと
生きてなかったからなんです
明日ということがあったんだからなんです
だから明日のこと妄想がひどいほど苦しみがひどいんです
で 震災っていうのはもう起こるもので
あ そうかということになれば
まあ全然問題はないんです
穏やかでいられます 雨が降ろうが乾期になろうがお釈迦様そうおっしゃっているんですね
何があっても安穏な穏やかな心でいられますと
だからみんなに同じ気持ちに乗っちゃってって
かなり悲しい出来事で
では 1 分間黙祷とかね
私にとっては個人的にはバカバカしくて
そういうことできないんです
すごく何かこう 何も考えてないんで
とにかく で テレビとかね
また再現してね もう無理やり泣いてほしい
だからなんで過去のものごと葬ったものをね
また放り出して ああ やっぱり臭い
やっぱりやっぱり怖いとかね
言って意図的に心を傷つけるんですかね
マスコミは だから黙祷の意味さえも
まあ人間として何かやりたいという気持ちは分かりますけど
あれ善行にはならないような気がします
だって亡くなられた方々のことを悲しく思い出すんだからね
私は参加する場合 私は生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと慈悲の瞑想するんです
心汚れたら終わると 黙祷といった途端
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと始まるんです
そんな西洋のね まあ何のもう発展していないね
文化的にはね かなり遅れている
で 西洋の真似ですからね
優れた文化をね ゴミ箱に捨ててやったんだからね
だからまあ そういうことで
仏教はね 死んだ人に何だらかんだらではなくて
よくどう生きるのかということでね
もうかなり強調しているんだから
諦めるしかないんですね
だからだから時間取り戻せないでしょうし
壊れたものは壊れたでしょうし
亡くなった方々は亡くなったでしょうに
で 福島の方でね もう家を捨てて出て行った方々はもう二度と戻れないでしょうに
だからそこは考えちゃうと苦しみがあって
それきれいさっぱり忘れて
新しい場所で元気よく生きていればいいでしょうに
今日しかないと だからそういうことを言うと
すごい私は乱暴で人を侮辱するとんでもない人やというふうに思っちゃいますね
でも だからといってね
あの もうあまりにも恐ろしいエボラウイルスに感染している人と一緒に抱きしめて
自分もウイルスに感染して欲しくないんです
一緒に泣きましょうよと
一緒に落ち込みましょうよと
一緒に PTSD に打ち込みましょうよと
もうわかりますよ もう私も泣いてみせたら
なんて素晴らしいお坊さんです
優しさで溢れているんです
だからもうもう勝手に私はもう年だからね
もう先がないんだから
意味がないんだから やめます
はい そういうことで この何で世界もね
すごいショックを受けましたし
日本だけではなくてね
あの悲惨な姿を見てね
あの変わり方 あの潰れていくことを見るとね
もうおっかない状態でね
やっぱりそこで ああ なるほど
全て無常だね もう呪われるもの何もないんだという仏教的な考えは出てこないんですね
執着するもんじゃない
執着したらもうこれそれがおっかないやと
私の家 壊れてる なるほど
流されたと だから執着するとそこに苦しみがあるんであってね
しかし このそういう災害は悲しみの原因になる理由が
我々は明日のために生きているんだからなんです
要するに生きていなかったからなんです
これから生きようとしたのにということなんです
それで死ぬまでこれから生きようとしまったと
いうことで輪廻転生する羽目になるんです
輪廻転生したって もうずっと準備中だからね
業だけ溜まるんです だからこの罠から出て行った方がいいんですね
だから今日はこの Trap of the Time というね
時間という罠というね
という概念を覚えていてください
皆様に悩み苦しみが生まれったら
ちょびっと自分の妄想を見てください
ハメられていますね時間に
それさえなければ 何に悩むのかと
だって全て夢中だから
何に怒るのか 何に嫉妬するのか
何に落ち込むのかと 一切の全て消えちゃって
究極の幸福 安穏がこのこの今ということにあるんですね
それっていうのはもうやっぱり経験してね
瞑想実践でもしてね 経験しなくちゃいけないと思います
で なければ この妄想の癖がね
かなり無限の過去からやってきたんだからね
無限の過去から一切の思考は時間という罠にハメられたもんなんです
時間抜けちゃうと 我々にとっては何もできなくなっちゃうんです
だからかなり心の訓練して
今っていうことに達するんですね
それは仏教で言う解脱
自由な境地なんです はい
それに対して生きる価値って何なのかというね
私たちは価値のある生き方していますかと
明日のために生きるならば
何の価値もないんです
[背景音楽]例えばね
もうなんて言いますかね
あれはなんて言いますか
結婚式 結婚の時ある着るなんとか服がありますね
なんて言いますかあれは
日本の人はウェディングドレス
ウェディングドレス それでこのずーっと毎日ウェディングドレスを作ると
しかし 永久的にはウェディングは来ないならば
これからするウェディングのために今ウェディングドレスを作っていると
どういうこと？何の安らぎもないでしょうに
それで九十歳になってまた縫っていると
まあ今流行が変わったんだから
やっぱりここをちょっと外して新しいもの
最初は作り出した時は帽子も被るのは流行
今帽子かぶりませんから
その代わりにこれ ずーっとそればっかりやって着る機会ないんです
それでまた新しいリボンをつけようと思ったところ
そのまま九十歳で死んじゃったと
生きたことないでしょう
心臓発作で死ぬ時でもリボンをつけようとしたところで
ウェディングドレスに
だから何かそれなりの映画もありますよね
そうやってね 過去に何かの幻覚に閉じ込められてっていうね
映画結構ありますね よく言うような普通なことでね
私たちも同じことをやってますね
過去 いわゆる時間に閉じ込められて
無限の苦しみを味わうというね
これはお釈迦様がなぜ知恵と
これは知恵の問題で知恵がないんですね
はい そういうことで この価値のある生き方は何なのかと Yo
ce vassa satan jive du silo va sama hito e kahan giv
i tan sey o sila wantassa
jahino du silo というのは戒を守らないということで
いわゆるいい加減わがまま感情で生きている
やりたいことをやって
もう百年生きていても
道徳を守って jahino
っていうのは自己観察しながら
いわゆる今にいるためにずっと観察が必要なんです
観察を止めたら もう妄想に行くんですね
だから その日は一日だけの命で
もう最高の命ですよ ってわけで
僕は別に長生きは描かせてないんです
歳生きるよりもね どーたくなき
普通に道徳を守ろうということはないし
みんなやってるんだから
みんなと同じことをやってますよと
いや それ言うことみんなと同じことをやって生きるというね
情けないと思いますよ
なんでみんなをモデルにするんですかね？みんなって誰のこと？はっきりしないでしょう
誰のことも知らないくせに
自分の子供だって何者かわからないでしょうに
随分いい加減 何か見てその真似する
何か見てその真似をする
だからそんなのは立派な生き方じゃないでしょうに
もう猿にも 劣る卑しい生き方になっちゃうんですね
だからみんなやってることではなくて
自分が何かしっかりした生き方しなくちゃと
そこではっきりくるのは道徳なんですね
だって原始脳が 妄想する脳がいつでも欲に
怒りに 憎しみに溺れているんだから
それで戒律を守るということは
自分が革命を起こそうとしているんですね
自分という自我の自己の
だから自己の革命を起こそうと
起こすべきなんですね
起こそうとしたあの一日に価値があるんです
自己革命を起こそうとして
できるできなかったってことじゃないんです
で 百十一になると Yo
ce vassa satāṃ jīvedi duppañño asamāhito, ekāhaṃ jīvi
taṃ seyyo paññavaṃ tassa
jāyino.デュッパンニョ
智慧がなくて アサマヒと精神統一すること
いわゆるサマーディ瞑想
何もやったことがなく
知恵もなく ただの人間で百年も生きてるんだと
何の価値もないんだと
一日でも知恵があったらジャアイノ
実践するならば 観察瞑想とかね
ものすごい価値があるんだと
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想で仰っているのは
その瞬間を実況する人が生きているんですよ
あの瞬間に価値があるんです
実況やめた途端 もう何の価値もない
ダラダラ妄想していて
百年じゃなくて年生きていたっても
もう何の意味もない 何の価値もない
だから知恵っていうのは
この今は知恵のあの現代的にこのタイム時間という問題を出してみせたでしょう
別に仏典ではそういうことはまあありますけどね
カーラという言葉について色々語られてね
で まあそれもなくて 現代的なプレゼンテーションの方がいいなと思ったんだからね
で 時間にはめられて生きていると
時間って妄想だと これ罠だと
何であろうと今の瞬間しかないでしょうと分かると
今の瞬間でも執着するものもないし
驚くものもないし 別に何のこともない
今の瞬間終わったら すぐ次の瞬間です
今の瞬間から次の瞬間という気持ちもなく
今の瞬間で今の瞬間 それで今の瞬間です
そういう風に考えちゃうと普通の思考と違うでしょう
それは知恵で考えることなんですね
知恵で見るとそう見えるんです
だから知恵があればね
例えばすべては夢 知恵なんです
分かったら これ欲しいなって言えないんだと
この花が綺麗って言えないんです
瞬間だけだからね 流れていくんです
自分も花も そういうことで
この価値ゼロのね 価値成り立たないゼロではなくてね
ゼロといったら価値ですからね
価値が成り立たない心身状態が智慧なんです
価値が成り立たないところは怒りもない
怒る 怒るために価値が必要でしょ
嫉妬はない 嫉妬するために価値が必要でしょ
落ち込みもない 落ち込むために価値が必要でしょ
欲はない 欲を抱くためにも価値が必要でしょ
だから価値あるないではなく
なく価値成り立たない
無常っていうのはそういうことなんです
その方向でちょっと考えたり
観察したり ヴィパッサナー実践でそれちょっと体験しようとしたりすると
その時間だけ本気で生きてるんです
現実的に あの年はただの夢を見ただけ
だから人がこのアムネシア
何とか病気にかかっちゃって
ずっと寝ている 起きない
それで年 年ずっと寝たっぱなし
一体何の価値もないでしょう
年もベッドで寝たままで
歳になって死んじゃったと
その人の人生に価値がある？生まれたらちょこっと何か病気にかかった
それで寝てしまった 脳はもうなかなか起きてこない
で 周りがその人を生かしてあげるんだからね
でも起きることはできません
ベッドのそのままで 外からもう無理やりに栄養を入れたりして
それでどんどん年は取りますよ
それで死んでしまう 素晴らしい人生
だから我々はずっとこの明日のために生きているんだから
もう寝ているんですね
だから明日のために生きることをやめて
今生きてみてほしいんですね
それが仏教の世界なんですね
だから智慧っていうのはそういうことなんです
はい 全部おなじみですから
次に行きます 百十二 ［異語］ちょっと発音間違った
［異語］クシートヒーネヴィーリョ
怠けで努力しない 今日覚えてください
お釈迦様が精密に怠け者
努力しない人というのは気づきがない時なんです
サティがない時は怠け者なんです
これは精密な定義で いくら人は頑張っていても
サティがなければ 気づきがなければ
仏教では怠け者と言うんです
なぜならば 気づく場合は
欲も怒りも嫉妬も憎しみ何の感情も働かないんですよ
自動的に気づきが生まれません
今の瞬間にいることはずっと意図的にやらなくちゃあかんのです
でないと だんと過去を将来が出てきて
自分を恐ろしい苦しみに潰し
潰しちゃいます だからその過去
将来が来ないようにずっと気をつけて気づきというものを持っていかなくちゃいかん
だから気づきさえなければ
気づきがなければ 仏教の精密な専門用語で
定義で言えば怠け者なんです
朝起きる 朝寝坊しまったっていうことは怠け者ではないんです
日 二時間しか寝ないでずっと頑張ってるんだと
これで年も二時間しか寝ないで頑張って
もう苦満長者になってるんだと
怠け者です 何の気づきもないんだから
［異語］例えば政治家とかね
政治家といったってどうってことないんだけど
総理大臣とかそういうかなり責任のある仕事になったら
もうずっと秒単位で仕事しなくちゃいかんですね
人に会う約束やったって
もう五分 十分とか決まっていて
十五分とかね ちょうどその時間で話したいものを話して
決断して 次のことに行かなくちゃいけない
えらい頑張ってるでしょ
怠け者です そういうことはないで
仏教ではこの気づきがある瞬間が怠けてないんです
ですから 普通でアメリカのオバマであろうか
もう安倍さんであろうか
もうもう百年生きてたって
もうゼロ価値だと ちょっと一日精進してみなさいよと
気づきを実践してみてくださいと
そちらに価値があるんだと
これ別な例で言えば このあらゆる国々の晩餐会について研究して喋るは喋るは
宮廷料理について研究して喋るは写真撮るは
あれやこれやとかね 一度も食べたことがなかったら
何の意味もないでしょう
だから晩餐会やら宮廷料理あれやこれやと考えて
あるいはちょっともうほんのわずかな料理でも
この間オバマが来た時は作ったあの皇居で
もう天皇陛下の前の晩餐
晩餐 何とかでディナーパーティーでこういう食べ物は作りましたよと
これ こういうもの じゃあ食べてみようかな
それで食べてるでしょうね
それに写真だらっと並んで
もう料理作った人の名前とか
もう経歴とか 材料を取り
どこから取り上げたかと取ったかどうか
あれやこれやとか 分厚い本をいくら読んだっても意味がないでしょうに
だからこんな人生 人生
だから怠けている怠け者の精進しない者の生き方は
いくら長くたっても意味がなくて
一日でも気づきを実践すると怠け者ではないし
それ価値があるんだということで
百十三 ［外国語］これでこの［外国語］というのは
現れては消える 現れては消える
現れては消えるという
このヴィパッサナーの智慧の一つなんですね
［外国語］と言いますけど
それ現れたらまあサッサッサッサと解脱には達します
もう自分もなくなっちゃって
今の瞬間 ないっていうことで観察してみると
観察すらできん もう観察しようと思ったらもう消えてる
また次の じゃあこれもうできない
だからウデッヴェニャーナが現れる時は大体言葉がないんです
頭の中で 実況中継 実況中継と言っても実況できんのです
まあずっと同じ あれ まあいろいろありますけど
まあまあなんとなく実況するだけで
本格的には実況もできない
もう確認しようとするともう消えている
確認しようと もう消えている
次の現象にアタックする
次 その瞬間のね あ もう消えちゃった
あってもう消えている
そういうものを発見するんですね
だから最初はもう集中力ないんだから言葉で確認しますけどね
で その場合はかなり長く今の瞬間取るんでしょう
左足上げるとどれぐらい秒かかってますかね
五 六秒かかってるでしょう
五 六秒は今ですかね だって秒で数えられますから
でもまあそういう訓練がどうしても欠かせないでしょう
そんな瞬間キャッチすることは私たちにできませんから
一応左足上げます 下げますということは
それもろくにやってないしね
妄想しながらね その世界に入らないんですね
世界に入ったら左足上げますって言ったっても
ダダダダーと現象が流れていることは体験します
びっくりします あ なんか言葉合わないんだと
左足上げてそんなこと起きてないんだと
わかるんですね そこはもう言葉にしないんですね
言葉にしないで ちゃんと言葉でしないで
物事の流れ見ることは智慧なんですね
だから経験は言葉にしちゃうと知識なんですね
だからお釈迦様の教えはもう誰にも敵わない
もういまだに純粋で 純粋というか
もう光り輝いて全く訂正する必要はない教えになっていてね
輝いている理由は智慧があるんですね
智慧が知識にしたんです
言葉にしたんです 智慧を言葉にしたんです
だからくだらない 腐ってる頭で哲学を考えてる人間には
ブッダの言葉 これ間違ってるっていうことを示すことはあり得ない
不可能 できない 怒りで苦しみ
憎しみで言いますよ 神の言葉はコーランだからもう間違っているんだよと
で ちょっと勉強 いえいえ
禁止しています コーランでは他の間違った宗教を勉強するのはと言ったらもう話にならんでしょうに
そういうもうもう必ず地獄は確定している人々は批判するかもしれませんだけど
普通の常識な人だったら
もうこれで間違ってるということはいまだに現れてない
はい だからそこをこの完璧に語り出したっていうことは
智慧がまずあって 智慧には言葉がない
だから喋れないとまず悩んだんだけど
じゃあ言葉を作っちゃえばいいんじゃないかって
それからゆっくりとお釈迦様はあらゆる言葉を考えて
概念考えて説法を始めたんですね
だから四聖諦ね 苦集滅道というね
それを最初にした言葉ですと言われていますけど
でも最初に言葉に思い浮かんだのはそれじゃないんだよ
お釈迦様の頭の中で 一切の出来事は現れて消えるものだと
そこを体験したらもう解脱涅槃だと
解脱涅槃ということもないんですね
それは後で作った言葉なんですね
全ての我が消えてよすがになるかと
五人のお坊様方に比丘たちに語る場合は
四聖諦をね 準備していたでしょうね
歩いている間で 悟りに達するために
まず生きるってどういうことかと
これが意味がないんだと
生きることに意味がないのに
なんで生きているのかと
何回生きてきたらやっぱりこういうこういう感情
渇愛で この感情さえなく渇愛さえなければ
この渇愛という 今日私は時間という風に使ったんだけどね
解放ではないかと それには正見正思惟しかないんだと
新たに物事を見なくちゃいかんと
伝統的に見てはあかんやと
あの人言ってるんだからってダメやろ
こんなのはと 自分で見る
ということで八正道とね
四聖諦を説かれて それからそれぞれ人に合わせて因果法則を説かれたり
で 五人の比丘たちはね
仏教にあって悟りに遇って預流果には悟りましたけど
阿羅漢にならないんでもうちょこっと残っているんですね
お釈迦様はなんでこの五人がね
一応智慧が現れた 預流果には悟りました
でもブッダと同じく完全に執着捨ててない
なんだこの五人はと ただバラモン人でしょう
永遠の魂があるということは
まだまだしっかり調べてないんですね
ブッダの教えはびっくり
もうもう納得 もうちょっと脳に問題残っていてね
だから まあみんな永遠に生きているんだというね
という生命もある考えがあったんですね
それで五人まとめてすごい怖い経典ですね
この教えたんですね 一切は燃えているというね
その経典 お釈迦様の話は
自我っていう錯覚を綺麗に破れてしまう
ありえないと そこでやっと完全に阿羅漢になってしまったんですね
アディッタパリアー一切は燃えている
いわゆるこのパリアーというのは
喩えとして 何か手段 道具として使う
ある角度なんですね だからバーニング
バーニングというもう概念にまとめて喋る
今日私はタイムというパリアーで喋ったんですね
話し始める前にタイム時間とはって
それで皆様の頭に時間という概念を作っちゃって
そこを使ってもう時間はないんだという風に持っていくんです
だから何か引っ掛けが必要なんですね
だからそれであの方々にバーニングね
燃えているという言葉で一切は燃やして見せた
燃やしてというのは精神的にも燃やしてみせたんですね
だから感じた すっぴで燃えているものだと
貪瞋痴で これで執着が消えてしまったんです
から それで歩くようになったんですね
ですから この智慧があって
自分が分かったものを人に言おうとすると
概念が必要で 言葉が必要です
そうなってくると知識になるんです
そうすると人の能力も言語達者で
ものすごい言語を覚えて勉強している人だったら
いくらでもフレーズ出てくるね
単語が出てくる ちょびちょびとしか何とか間に合う程度で言語を喋る人にとっては智慧があってもちょっと語らないんですね
それで歩く場合はちゃんと集中して左足上げると言った途端
左足これ成り立たない
あげると言ったって もうたくさん無数の現象が現れては変化する
びっくりするんですね
足っていう概念消えちゃって
上げるという概念も消えちゃって
生滅生滅だけ せいぜい生滅だけやって言葉
言葉さえ出てこないんですね
それでびっくりした経験ですけど
この経験をどうやって報告するのかということで知識になってくるんですね
だから その瞬間が言葉にしたらウデッアッベと言うんですね
生滅の智慧 もし誰かが生滅の智慧が発見したら
その人は一時間しか生きていられなかったと価値があります
友達二人がいるとしましょう
一人が観察して生滅の智慧を発見しちゃったんだけど
その瞬間で何か山崩れでも何かあってもう潰されて死んじゃったと
もう一人の友達が周り見ていて
あ 山崩れって逃げちゃって
命拾いして年まで生きて
あの私の友達 バカがね
なんか何か自分の世界に入り込んじゃってね
見抜きできなくなっちゃって死んじゃったって
バカやろ 違います あの人は生滅を発見したんだから見得はないんです
見抜きできないんです
その瞬間に山が崩れて死んじゃったっていうのは
その人は生きていたんです
あの人の年の人生 何の価値もないんです
汚れた心で幻覚でいるだけ
百十四に行きます ［外国語］同じ偈で今度はアマタパダ
不死の境地 これも不死って仏教用語の不死っていうのは難しい
言葉じゃないんです 不死
死は成り立たない 例えば今の瞬間って死ってください
何も成り立たない 死っていうことは時間が必要なんですよ
田中さんが死んじゃったというためには
時間のあの罠 あの妄想が必要なんです
でなきゃ成り立たないんです
我々が使う全ての概念は時間に汚染されてますね
喋った途端 だから不死ってどう天国みたいなところですかと考えるんですね
不死の境地ってどこにあるのかとかね
時間で考えるんです そんな場所ない
そんな場所がなかったら不死は存在しないんだよ
だからね まあだから場所がない
なく存在するものもありますよ
いくらでもあります 例えば田中さんは博士です
博士っていうのはどこにいるとか
どこに行けば博士になる
例えば この田中さんが博士号を取ったのは東京大学で取りましたよと
もう時間にはめられているんですね
だから タイムにスペース両方入ってるんですね
それで じゃああなたも東大に行けば
まあ二百 三百円ぐらいで行けますよ
そんな難しくないんです
駒場学校だったら歩いたっても行けるぐらいです
だから博士 それは田中さんはね
1985年 じゃあ1985年東大にいたみんな博士ですかね
だからそこは田中さん博士とか時空関係ないんですね
で これは完璧な例えではないんだけど
まあなんとなくね 博士はどこにいるのかいと
あなたの博士見せてくださいと
何を見せる 名刺 名刺がなくなったら博士ではない
あるいは自分の大学の研究室に書いている看板
誰かあの看板を持っていったら
この人の博士号もなくなる
あるいは論文 論文がもう火事で燃えてしまったと
まあ終わり 博士号もパーですかね
誰にもそれを取り上げることはできん
論文がなくなっても田中さんは博士です
田中さんの仕事場の書いている看板
誰か剥がして持っていっても全然大丈夫です
誰かが田中さんのね 名刺全部持っていったんだから
あるいは国の法律で田中さんに名刺を作ることを禁じると
で博士消える？消えることできないんですね
だから緒方さんの博士取り上げられたでしょ
取り上げられますね それだったら
取り上げられません 本当は
緒方さんの場合はもういろいろねつ造しちゃったんだから
大学は博士と勘違いしただけ
だから初めからも名刺
実質の博士ではなかったんですね
だから大学は偉そうに博士号取り上げますと言ったのは
それは私から見れば論理合ってないんです
緒方さんは最初からもう博士ではなかったと
ということになるんです
そういうことで この 時空関係と関係ないものはあるんですよ
だから田中さんが死んじゃっても博士は死なないんです
死ぬのは田中さんなんですね
で  二十六歳で博士になったと
で 田中さんが八十五歳で死ぬ
そうすると博士号も六十年ぐらい年老いた？老いてないでしょう
老いたのは田中なんです
私の博士号も本当はもう年取っちゃって
ボロボロやと言える 時空関係から抜けてますね
それは だから仏教でいうこういう観念的なことではなくて
存在現象について現象が成り立たないということを発見すると
そちらに不死という単語を使わなくちゃだから不死は知識の言葉で
経験は智慧で だからアマタンパダンというのは涅槃に使うもう一つの言葉で
不死の境地 涅槃ですね
涅槃を経験することがなく
百年でも何百年いたってもただの無駄だよと
本当の価値のある生き方っていうのは
不死の境地を経験することです
びっくりしますよ この空しい生き方がなくなったと
はい 最後に行きます ヨーチャワッササタンジーウェーアパッサンダンマムッタマン エーカハンジービタンセイヨーパッサトーダンマムッタマン
なんか結論みたいな偈なんですね
で この超越したウッタマンっていうのは無常という
まぁまぁ優れたというね
俗世間の考えは俗世間で俗世間と違う優れた思考はウッタマという言葉を使っているので
この真理をね 法というよりは真理ですね
この超越した真理を見ることなく
いくら生きていたっても意味のない無駄な生き方であった
真理を発見したら それは価値のある生き方
それで真理について百十から百十四までちょっと具体的に語られて
それをまとめて 結局は真理だということで
十五番目の百十五番目は終了
結論の偈になるんです
そこでダンマは真理で法で
こっちはウッタマン 優れたというふうにするんですね
だから俗世間ででも生きることって大変だ
欲張ってはあかんやってのは真理の言葉なんですね
殺してはならん もう喧嘩してもならんね
あれこれと言ってるんです
我々も それもちゃんと
憎しんではあかんやとかね
落ち着いていなくちゃあかんと
どうせもうこんなものは持ってきたわけでもないんだから
死ぬ時は全部持って持って行けるものじゃないんだから
置いておきましょうよということは普通にも言えますね
だからそれも真理ですけど
経験してないんですね
心が次元破ってないんですね
罠から逃げてないんです
夢の中にいると 夢から目覚めた状況わからないんだけど
もうなんとか だから刑務所で生まれた赤ちゃんがいるとしましょう
それで親がもう終身刑
終身でもう六十歳になっても
だから子供も普通はそれ法律違反ですけど
やってないんだけど まあ子供が生まれて
子供も三十歳で この子はちっちゃい頃から刑務所に出たでしょ
その子にとっては自分の住んでる世界で何のこともないんです
いろんなおじさんおばさんたちが檻の中に
別にどうってことない
自分好きな檻に入って好きなところに出られるし
別な檻に入って遊びたければそちらに行けるし
で ジェイラーたちとね
ちょっとカードゲームでもやりたければそれもできるしって
だから本人にとって何のこともないんですね
でも刑務所から逃げたことはないならば
それを世界と勘違いしていますね
でもどんどんなんとなく外の世界あるんだと
で わかることも可能なんですね
そういうことで この幻覚にはめられていて
幻覚から逃げてないんだけど
あれ これって幻覚だろうということぐらいわかりますね
理解できます だから私たちもいろいろ仏教
あれこれ学んで まあ恩返しでいろんなことを言いますね
恩返しってわけでもなく
時々本気で言う場合もありますね
怒ってはいけませんとかね
であれやこれやとか言ったりはしますね
その場合はダンマを言ってるんだけど
ウッタマダンマンではないんです
優れたダンマではないんです
だからダンマにもダンマとウッタマダンマと二つランクがあります
無常のダンマっていうのは解脱の経験者なんですね
現れては消えるっていうことは皆さんも知ってるでしょう
真理ですね でもダンマです
ウッタマダンマンではないんです
現れては消えること そのまま経験しちゃうと自分存在しないでしょう
そこがウッタマダンマンなんです
現れては消える 私知ってますよと
自分がいるんだから経験していないんです
現れたら消えることを経験すると
自分が現れては消えるんだから
これ言葉上しか成り立たないんですね
だからその言葉超えてますね
違う言葉超えてます 一種でもね
そういうことでウッタマダンマンマンっていうのは
まあもういわゆる解脱に達した人のことで
具体的には百十から百十四まで
もう語れています はい
そういうことで 無明で無知で明日ために生きる人生には価値がない
今日で生きる人生なら
今生きる人生だったら価値がある
今生きる人にとっては悩み苦しみがない
すごく安らぎがあるんです
しかし 脳に問題がありまして
脳が幻覚がなければ動かないんですね
過去か将来がなければ頭が動かないんですね
変です  [終始背景音楽]だって私もね
まあ明後日の講演の準備しましょうとかね
それで頭働かしちゃって
そういう頭が変なんですね
だからもう本当私はこのギリギリ明日講演あるならば
夜12時になってもまだあのパワーポイントをオープンしてないんです
12時過ぎで12時半になってくる
もう時間間に合わないやと
自分遅いんだから 仕事するの
それでやっと書き出すんです
やっぱりギリギリ今の瞬間になったらデータが現れるんです 2
日前  1週間前に講演作ったっても
通じるかどうかはよくわからない私も
私の怠けのせいかどちらかわかりませんだけど
もうものすごくギリギリその場でなければどうしてもデータがないんですね
頭の中で その時のことに興味が行っちゃうんです
はい まあそうで 我々の頭っていうのは
過去の幻覚か将来の幻覚が作って思考する
だからそんなのは妄想なんですね
結局は 正しい思考っていうのは知恵があって
この知恵をどうやって人間に語れるのかというと
知識 正しい思考なんです
その場合は 私たちも思考するつもりですけど
あの枠に入ってるんですね
タイムという そうすると結局は妄想なんです
はい そういうことで 一般の世界は
悩む 損害が受けたと悩む
真理の世界で損害は受け起きません
災害が起きたと悩む これは真理の世界では災害は成り立ちません
だから災害を受けたという瞬間で過去と比較していますよ
家が潰れました 言った
大変だ 家が潰れて家が火事になってしまう
やっぱり過去 なんです
それで大変苦しむんです
無常は手に負えないんです
無常は放っとくものです
管理不可能です 私たちは時間にはまっているんだから
無常を管理しようとする
無常は無常でないと思ったりする
家を作ったんだから まあ家やなんとか借金でローンで作ったんだけど
今45歳で 70歳までずっといられるだろうとかね
と思っちゃうんですね
ということは家は壊れません
自分も70歳まで生きられる
という無常に逆らった思考で生きてるんだからなんですね
そうすると  70  80歳まで生きたがっている人が
50歳で癌になっちゃうと悩むでしょ
逆も同じ  50歳で死にたかった人がもうもう90歳までまだ死なない場合はもうもう 30年間も嫌々で悩んだ話なんです
だから無常から逸れたところで悩み
苦しみがあるんですね
だから災害という単語さえも無常に逆らった単語で
だから悲しむんです 年取ったっていう単語は時間にはめられた単語でしょ
だから年取るっていうことは嫌なんですね
聞きたくはない だから無常に逆らってるんです
ありえないことをね 地球の自転に逆らうような感じ
俺は逆らってやるぞと
頑張ってくださいと 地球は自転すること
放っておけばいい だから地球は自転するっていうこと
わかってない時もその時わかってないんだから放っておいた
今はわかってるんだけど
放っておいているんだから
別に問題ないでしょうね
はい そういうことで 仏教はこのようなこの智慧をいじることによって悩み苦しみを乗り越える
安穏を得られる生き方をする
話はそこら辺で終了します
どうもありがとうございます
はい ありがとうございます
今八時四十分ですので
一応九時までという予定になってますので
少しお時間がございます
もし質問などありましたら挙手していただければマイクを回します
それでは奥の方の方にマイクを回していただきます
あのちょっと手を上げておいていただけますか？わかりやすいように
今 長老のお話 お話を聞いていて
自分の中でその話はわかりますと実感したことがあったのですが
ただそれは前に長老の本を見た時もわかりましたと思った実感もあって
ただ その時と今わかりましたと思う
実感はやはりちょっと違うなっていうのを感じていて
自分自分で判断したわかりましたっていうことは
実際どこまでその時点で自分がわかっているのかっていうのは自分では判断できないんだなっていうのを今ちょっと法話を聞いて感じていました
ただ 自分がわかりましたって感じると
それに満足をする自分がいて
その時点で少しその学びが止まってしまうというか
私はもうここについてはわかってるんだって思い込んでしまっている自分もいて
その先に進まなくなってしまうっていう感覚を持つことがあるんですが
その普段聞いてて実感としてわかることがあるんですが
それを感じながらも学び続けるというか
どういう心構えで日々聞いていけばいいのかっていうのが
ちょっとわからないことがあるんですが
それについてもし何か
お聞かせください  だからいろいろなことは人間がわかりますよ
だからわかっ たことは
この時間のあれに入れちゃうとトラブっちゃうんですね
それで自我が出てきたり
自分で判断したり あれやこれやとかね
だから今も同じフレーズで答えたんだけど
分かったら分かったでそれで終わっちゃったんでしょうにね
だからこの同じことを分かってるかもしれません
だから私はいろんなパリアやいろんな方弁というかね
いろんなもう言葉をね
持ってきて喋ってますよ
だから今日はtimeと時間という言葉を持ってきたんですね
持ってきてない 突然思い出しちゃったんです
こちら座ってから だからそれに皆様も新たな考えで
ああなるほどという風になってくるんですね
だからまあ同じことでもね
蕎麦は蕎麦ですけど 食べ方いろいろでしょ
そんな感じでね 問題ないと思います
それは時間に入れておくと
煩悩になっちゃって 自我になっちゃって
成長が止まったりする
おっしゃった問題 全部起こるんですね
だからこの何か人の 私の話に限らず
何か人が言ったことが自分が分かったら
それで喜べばいいでしょう
喜んで終わった この分かったことはどの程度のものかと比較するためには
あの恐ろしい鬼が 時間という鬼が必要なんです
そいつは何か説明してくれるんじゃなくて
ハチャメチャにするんです
だから今日の話は仏教ではどんな程度の理解でしょうかと思った時点で
あの鬼が来るんですね
鬼が仏教の反対なんですね
だからせっかく喜んだのに
あの喜びを壊しちゃうんです
これあんたちょっと傲慢じゃない？分かった分かったとかね
あれこれとなっちゃうんですね
ですから まあ素直に生きてみましょうよ
今の瞬間が分かった よかった
楽しかった 終わったと
この前の話は 本読んでもなんかいろいろ面白いなと
分かったことがありましたとかね
今日の話でもなんかいろいろいろいろ分かったとかね
それでいいんじゃないですかね
どこまでっていうのは
あれはえらい臭い単語なんですね
だから私の答えはまあ素直に分かった
ちょっと分からないね
あなたの話は そんな程度でいいんですね
まあ分からないっていうことは
妄想 妄想中だったら分からない
人の話は大体分かります
時に私の話は分かるはずなんです
私はこの人の脳がどう動くのかとチェックしながら喋ってるんです
脳の中でどうやって論理が成り立ってるのかと
皆様は論理がまるそう方ないかもしれませんが
脳が論理的だからね だからそこをチェックしながら喋ってるんだから
一応妄想さえしなかったら分かります
まあそれで分かった はい
さようならでいいんです
それで あの本当のところ分かったっていうことは
それから自分のパースペクティブ
ものの見方 自分の生き方
価値観も変わったら 変わったら結構残る分かり方
分かったっていうことですね
まあ元の通りの人間になっちゃったら
元の悩み 苦しみ 落ち込む
傲慢の人間に戻っちゃったならば
まああまり本物じゃないんですね
だからあのジワジワと我々がなんとなく人格が向上して
執着が減っちゃって 明るく軽く生きられるようになっていると
例えば ある日何か変なことが起きちゃって
まあ昔なら私はそんなことで大騒ぎするでしょうね
今はもう冷静だと 今はそんな程度のことではね
揺らぎませんよという人間になってるならば
結構変わってるんですね
だから分かることで 仏教は人格向上を考えているんですね
人格向上かないかということは
もののパースペクティブ
どんな風にものを見ているのかと
だからこれは無常で見られるようになってほしい
無常が真理ですからね
どんどん無常のパースペクティブで無常の尺度で尺度って
パースペクティブっていうのはもうちょっと違いますけどね
無常の立場で見られるようになる
相当成長していますね
普通人間っていうのは
仏教を学んでいる人々は無常は忘れちゃいますよ
時々意図的に無理やり
やっぱり無常だなとか思ったりする
それはそれでよろしいんですけど
そうじゃなくて 何のことなく無常だというね
ある日 何か私の部屋である人がね
何かやろうとしたら 何かちょっと壊れちゃったんですね
ある品物はね お茶入れようと思ったんで
あれで蓋の 取るところ壊れちゃったんですね
それを私に言わないで
こういう紅茶入れるポットをね
どこで買ったんですか？とかね
どこにあるんですか？私なんで
忘れちゃったよと いいところこちらのポット破れたんだから
だから何やと あんたそれ壊れないと思ってたんですか？とかいい加減にしないとバカと怒ったんです
だから怒ったのは壊れたことではないんです
私は あの子の馬鹿さなんですね
あんたこれ壊れないと思ったのかと
これ直せる？これこれなるで直りませんよと
元に戻しませんよと いい加減にしろと怒っちゃって
それから私は直しましたけどもね
今も使ってますよ で だからあ
壊れたということが そんなもんかと
だからあ 壊れたというところでショックなんですね
という場合は無常の見方ではないんですね
やっぱりというところは無常の見方なんですね
どちらで心が安らぎ感じるかというと
壊れているのに安らぎを感じる
だから そういう風に仏教を学ぶことによって
我々のこのパースペクティブというものはどのように見ているのかと
ということで この今 貪瞋痴で見ている
永遠不滅やという色眼鏡で見ている
壊れて欲しくないという希望的な観察で世の中見ている
年は取って欲しくないと病気になって欲しくない
希望的観察でしょ あれ
それは英語でウィッシュフルシンキングと言うんですね
だからこの自分が希望してそのものように世の中見るんじゃなくてね
無常で見られる やっぱりどう見たって無常やこれはとかね
止まらないんだ これはとか見られるようになってきて
心に安らぎある 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみ減っているならば本物の成長ぶりです
これで自己観察してください
はい  はい ではもう一方前のほうにマイクを回していただきます
よろしくお願いします
過去過去を思い出す能力はどのようなものなんでしょうか
今しかないならば  それは 2つありますね
我々は感情があって この感情でね
今の状況からなんか引っ掛けがあって過去を思い出したりする
それでろくな過去じゃないんですよ
みんなそういう風に過去を思い出したりするんだけど
いい加減で中途半端で曖昧でしっかりしていないんです
だから正しい過去を思い出すということは
ハードディスクのデータを読み上げるような感じで
ありのままに過去を見られること
それには感情があるとできないんです
だから 起きた起きた起きた現象だから歴史だからね
何年何月何日何秒でこういうこういうことが起きましたとというふうに思い出すならば
正しい記憶なんですね
私たちにそうじゃなくて
なんか例えばラーメン食べてるんだけど
ちょっと塩味がきつくて
それで思い出しちゃいます
この間のなんだか食べたら
そんな立派な 過去じゃないんですね
だから夫婦喧嘩になるし
みんなとトラブルちゃうしね
親にしたってもね 親の都合で気に入ってる場面だけ子供のね
覚えているんですね それで子供いじめるのお前はね
昔ちゃ違いますけど だから一般の人々の過去の思い出はそういうものになるんですね
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想をやってみると
それは結構 あの 何といいますか
この汚れが落ちるんです
何の執着もなく まあもうこういうことあった
こういうことあったとかね
思い出すことはできます
で あの現代的に言えば
この脳の中でね あるこの原始脳には何かありますね
なんか変なブリッジみたいなね
海馬なんとか言いますけどね
で そちらですね データ記録するハードディスクあるのはね
ハチャメチャなんで 汚れだらけでウイルスだらけでうまく動かないんですね
だって原始脳が私たちの大脳新皮質より余計なことやってるんだからね
やっていけないこと で
大脳からデータ入れるんだけど
これ汚れたもう血管だらけでのハードディスクにデータ入れちゃってもまた復活できるけどわからないでしょ
ファイルはどこにあったかもわからないしね
これヴィパッサナー瞑想やってみると
この原始脳のこの記憶する
あのブリッジと言いますか
そこら辺は落ち着いて健康になります
そうするとちゃんとパッパッと取り出すことはできますね
例えばメールたくさんありましてね
うーん チャット何かだから何か検索言葉入れちゃうと
そこに関連あるメールがサッと今パソコンで出てくるでしょ
そういうふうな感じで
ちゃんとパソコンはちゃんと論理的で整理整頓
一応頑張ってやってますからね
私たちできなくてもね
だからいろんな人とメールやりとりやっていてね
ある人が言ったことを
例えばもう田中さん 田中さんかわいそう
田中さん 前のメールないかと田中と検索すれば
もうそこを田中が送ったメール全部いっぺんに出てくるんですね
我々の脳のハードディスクはそう働かないでしょ
だから今の記憶力 そういういい加減であてにならないトラブルばっかしで
思い出したら失敗するだけで
どうにもならん 例えば試験に行ったら勉強したものを忘れるでしょ
他遊んだことを思い出しちゃうんですね
なんじゃこれはと だからこの
その TPI に合わせて必要なものをサッと取り出せることが本物の記憶力なんですね
それは成長育てたければ
あの マインドフルネスというね
その瞑想しなくちゃあかんですね
タイムズ雑誌であったんですね
このマインドフルネストレーニングして
子供のね 計算能力とスピードがすごい上がったんだと
この比較してね マインドフルネストレーニングした子供としてない子供に大体同じ能力あったんだけど
それで結構早く早くなって能力も上がったと
という記事があってね
どうせタイムズマガジンの記事だから読まなかったんです
斜めに読んで終わっちゃった
はい そういうことだから
一応ね あんなのは遊びでね
やってることで こちら本物だからね
結構記憶力はね 残ります
しかし 過去の罠がオニに入っちゃうとね
過去は起きたもので 歴史のデータとして思い出すだけで別にどうってことないんですね
歴史勉強してそういうこと歴史存在しないでしょう
歴史だから勉強するんであって
だからまあ今そうじゃなくて
過去を思い出した途端にやられちゃいますね
その過去の思い出に だから時間の罠に足が取られてるんですね
だから過去を思い出して悩む
過去を思い出してちょっと調子に乗るとかいろいろある
そこで面白いことにやっちゃう
過去っていうのは作るんです
組み合わせて 自分で知らない
これ組み合わせたからそんなこと起きてなかったよとわかってないんです
だからもう頭の中でいろんなドラマを作ってますね
だから気づきの瞑想した方が脳細胞はかなり整理整頓がされます
一応二つ寄りだと思ってください
うん  ありがとうございます
はい それではあの まだあるかもしれませんけど
ちょうど9時になりましたので
もう遅いのでこれで終了したいと思います
ちょっとマイクいいですか
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝帰依し
彼を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして苦楽が得られますように
サッビートゥワッジャンツーサッバローゴウィナッサトーマーテーバワットワンタラーヨスッケーディーガーイコーバワーバウトサッバマンガランラッカントサッバデ
ーバタサッバブッダヌーバヴェーナサッバダンマヌーバヴェーナサッバサンガヌーバヴェーナサダーサッティバワントテー
アビワダナシーリスニッチャンワッダパチャヤーナチャッターローダンマワッダンティアウィワンナーสุขัง
ありがとうございます
サードサードサード